thousands of teachers say they have no
confidence in the leadership of the
Clark County Superintendent now this
comes as the Nevada legislature is
proposing investing two billion dollars
in education funding pretty big chunk of
it is going to Clark County Schools
eight news now educational reporter
Joshua peguero hears from both sides on
this issue
Governor Joe Lombardo promised earlier
this year to bring historic funding to
Nevada schools yet the Clark County
teachers union says CCSD leadership
isn't qualified to spend it we have
graduation rates that are suspect we
have our low proficiency rates we have
the Gap that continues to get bigger
between our most at-risk students and
our other students and then we're not
graduating students who are College and
Career ready in a statement sent to
eight news now from the Clark County
Education Association it says quote
several thousand Educators participated
in the survey and 75 percent have no
confidence in his ability to effectively
spend these funds to improve student
outcomes ccea represents more than
eighteen thousand Educators ccea
president Marie nicest says
superintendent Dr Jesus jara's policies
and plans aren't effective there aren't
plans that are forward-thinking so how
can we continue to address these issues
that our students are facing that issue
ccea has is improving student outcome
across the district something a district
tells me it is committed to
superintendent Jara spoke before
lawmakers on March 31st defending his
leadership and says before his 2018
hiring the district struggled we looked
at the expectations
that we set
before
coming out of covid we didn't have any
of these systems so there was an adult
driven culture to protecting adults
protecting special interests
versus protecting our children CCSD
currently has 97 one-star schools
schools that stand to benefit from the
new funds Joshua peguero eight news now
we heard back from Clark County Schools
late this afternoon on that matter the
district saying in part this is an
attempt by ccea who barely represent
half the teachers in CCSD to influence
contract negotiations in a bad faith
attempt to Leverage What little
credibility they have left with teachers